oh
why did why did she get the surprise
question okay
I have something to tell you
[Music]
[Music]
uh I'd be great if these questions how
to twist yeah
like I have a big crush on you but
I've got a big dick
I'm sorry that's the only thing I had to
be here to do today
I'm here to tell someone I have a crush
on them what's the worst part of being
single
you both are single right yeah yes all
right any of you guys dating right now
no no the worst part is like when you
want to do something and you just like
have yourself like do something like
what
[Music]
ah you better get it girl I think
feeling lonely sometimes
some of the stuff that you want to do
you really got to do it with right with
your partner like I ain't trying to hit
up my voice to go you know
okay oh have you ever pictured me naked
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
have you ever pictured me naked
[Music]
[Laughter]
and that's a lie
he's never pictured you naked have your
Perfection Nick have you ever pictured
me naked
Miss Lalu gay to you
hey yo
yo
yeah
when
may or may not been in a dream was it a
good dream
definition
he's been thinking about you right now
but we'll be he didn't even finish his
Center she said was it a good dream
the fridge was it a good drink he's like
it was a good distance it was a
feels so good hi hi Stephanie Yang
do you want to Yin Yang with me
hey Stephanie
if your parents reject us
I'll take over the world and make them
bowed out
and you always got to finish it off with
one of these
little glass of sound effect it's an
anime thing you wouldn't get it yeah I
get it no no you don't get it
is the drooling thing an anime thing too
we gotta we gotta add our own spin on it
nasty ass you didn't add you you didn't
add your own pin you had your own spit
yes but I also recycled it by putting it
back in my mouth
this is embarrassing I've had dreams
about you proposing to me hey yo hey you
made my dick sauce
Bella ring knife and foreign
[Laughter]
give me a big whiff how do I smell yeah
oh he smelled like yeah you gotta get in
the armpits in the armpits okay
hey yo hey
man you know the Jubilee producers say
being the messiest person on these days
all right he's one of those mystery
characters who like does all the Kingpin
[ __ ] from the dark you know what I'm
saying he like he never comes out of the
Shadows you just sit there and he got
his little cat on his lap on the seat
yeah and he purrs it he's like yes
go through her phone
use the search function
now write P look for the grapefruit
what was it
uh eggplant look for the eggplant you
said grapefruit what does that mean what
is that grapefruit
I [ __ ] up what would a grateful mean I
know what it would be it's a technique I
know it
pause
that's like you said you were gonna do
it
thank you
and wait I thought she was supposed to
be obviously
no no no no no she knows what the [ __ ]
she doing now two things it's either
it's on like Donkey Kong oh she taking
advantage because she likes the
attention
and I've seen girls like that they not
gay are they not gay but they like the
attention of studs and [ __ ] so they roll
around in the play to be an old tease
like that yeah I've seen that this girl
when she pulled up with the titties and
put it against the head she's like oh my
bad and the girl kind of leaned away but
she like went back and leaned in and
went
like you could see if you watch very
carefully we'll watch
it's like when you say no but you really
want to say yes yeah
come back here yeah I'll give it yeah
I'll give you that one it not as bad but
why does like make it here
smells good dick is hard
oh how would you rank yourself in bed
scale of one to ten I feel like you know
the skill is not really applicable right
here you said numbers don't matter
let me say like
honestly probably like it too like
pretty low I respect it at least you're
honest yeah because most women I know
over rate their skills I don't know I'm
not particularly talented
what's your least favorite and most
favorite sex position
do you want me to like demonstrate
um
foreign
you can do that
I should probably take the shot
how attractive am I she knows what she
did you see this
seated did you how I am
attractive am I she knows what the [ __ ]
she's doing a hundred percent on a scale
from one to ten it could be a nine thank
you you know what I mean
guess what
phone is questioning she has to ask
I have a crush on me
is that just a card or an action yeah
well I mean yeah I mean I like reading
the card but I'm like
really easy yeah do you have similar
feelings for me
I have a crush on you
oh my gosh this is so cute
stop playing do you have similar
feelings I'm playing
it's gonna be hilarious he's like no I'm
straight [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] how come you even suck on
these titties some would say
foreign
feelings for you or whatever
are you surprised
what you said what you said
we [ __ ]
sure I I have feelings for you he went
you might now [ __ ] this is what you
want to do bro when you smash it right
just as you're about to come she's like
yes I want it I want it she's like yeah
and you still a 9 out of ten [ __ ]
this feels this is more relieving than
anything because I feel like honestly I
felt like the way we've been hanging out
like the tension has been there so why
don't you say anything cause you haven't
said anything whoo whoo girl no it's not
her job you want to say something say
something you want to say something so
you said it there you go yeah sorry I
just got PTSD a bit from when I was a
kid yeah remember
I gotta I got a little bit of PTSD
that's the thing so the thing is you
know I mean you chill in the
[ __ ] and everything and stuff
like you know you're an ugly kid right
nobody's nobody nobody's on your side
you know I mean this is not Nationwide
you know I mean they they don't give a
[ __ ] about you nobody and he chill he's
just being quarters because you don't
want to be a [ __ ] creep and then
admit it the [ __ ] minute the
minute my [ __ ] the minute the second
all right that you have a girlfriend
like oh [ __ ] you got a girlfriend yeah
how to cross on you [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
oh cool
oh
why didn't you say something cause you
didn't say to me oh my God to me it was
never a problem because soon as the girl
told me that I dumped my girlfriend be
like let's [ __ ] so I mean we working it
out one way or another uh it's like you
know when you have a good friendship I
feel like you don't want to rush
anything or just like make a move too
quick are your boyfriend girlfriend
you didn't want to be what
I don't know why this whole portion is
just cringe
what a what a weird way to ask someone
to be your boyfriend I like the date was
fine
you want to be a boyfriend girlfriend
this producer better ask him to make out
yeah it's up to you
I'm down I'm dancing
what are you doing tomorrow tomorrow and
tomorrow night
um I'm free yeah I'm free I'm free how
would you like to go out smart oh this
[ __ ] turned into D'Angelo what
the [ __ ] how would you like to Bing Bing
how would you like to baby
I don't know maybe
[Music]
Bingo hat with me
you
think
[Music]
go out with me girl
[Music]
could turn into a [ __ ] get he
started through a whole intro
hey this motherfucker's about to bite
his lip watch
[Music]
I dare you to kiss me
thank you
there you go
this you
this shoe this this shoot
this you
Bing [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm scared now
I dare you to kiss me
My [ __ ] My [ __ ] yeah if it's me I'm
coming in stand up come over here and
I'm grabbing a handful of ass at the
same time
moving that table out the way I mean it
depends moving that table out the way
she got that oh I'm a nine out of 10
energy yo I'm getting a handful of that
ass
[Music]
the producer alone
this is Magic I made magic people I made
magic I'm amazing they found love
in Abraham plays hopeless hopeless
purpose I don't think [ __ ] it's broken
Rihanna's from your country no she's not
she's from Barbados is that where you're
from
what the [ __ ]
I've got one of the [ __ ] uh hurricane
countries
are the ones that disappear every year
you're a fall as [ __ ] you yeah my driver
dude [ __ ] whatever what's your last
name don't worry
I'll be underwater anyway
[Laughter]
okay